I am a postdoc at the University of
Washington in the Department of
astronomy and II Science Institute you
will probably hear about the Science
Institute a little more later today and
I'm going to so my main focus is on sub
field of astronomy I'm interested in
cosmology and that's the study of the
expanse of the evolution of the universe
with all of its different phases and the
reason there is a connection with all of
this is the way we do this is we have
theories and models which we then
confront with data and the data comes
from astronomical service which in some
sense is this this kind of data is
pretty messy so extracting information
from that and actually matching up to
all of this except quite a bit of work
and the language the computer language
that i have been using almost
exclusively for the past few years is
python so what and before i go on i
would like to point out that i'm going
to talk about some stuff with the LSST
which is the name of a survey large
synoptic sky telescope and this work has
been a lot of the work has been done
with the people here listed as part of
the alice st group in the university of
washington and also a lot of the work
actually is done with kyle barbary who's
in at UC berkeley and so what i want to
do here is I will first try to share why
I personally find cosmology and in
particular I'll only talk about
supernova cosmology why I think this is
sort of interesting what the scientific
problem is and then I try to describe
the kind of data that we are going to
get we get and we are going to get to
I study this problem and that'll help
help i hope in explaining what the
issues are that we have to handle and
then i'm going to discuss this icon code
as in cosmo which we have been using for
a while now to work with supernovae and
finally i am going to try to come up
with this example where we are trying to
generate simulation catalogs for LSST
and i'll try to show how some of the
work that we have done with sm cosmo can
be taken in and used for that so the
first thing that i kind of want to bring
to you is that I think that the universe
is an excellent laboratory for testing
certain kinds of physics so we usually
think of testing physics in laboratories
and you have much better control of data
there but looking at the sky actually
gives you certain things that you can't
get otherwise one is you can probe
physical effects at very long time
skills and also at very large spatial
scales which is why there are certain
kinds of physical effects that you can
see very well here and as an example
sort of saying that this is not just
thoughts there are at least two effects
you know historically this has been very
useful but right now at least there are
two effects that we see two
discrepancies of observation with
theoretical understanding that are
usually spoken in terms of dark matter
and dark energy that we see from these
kinds of observations that you can't see
in any terrestrial laboratory and it is
I believe because it probes a different
length scale and time scale ok so just
to say a bit more about that dark matter
is essentially saying that there is
observational evidence
that the gravity that we see in stellar
objects or the universe at large is
stronger than it would be then it would
be if you thought of all the particles
that you could see so that needs to be
either more particles are something else
dark energy is observational evidence
for accelerated expansion of the
universe at late times which you
wouldn't expect without either a
different kind of gravity or another
kind of substance that you might not
have suspected so this is kind of an
image that has become fairly popular in
the last decade when the satellite w map
was up and it kind of shows a bit of
this so the way you're supposed to look
at this picture is time flows to the
right and what this conical type of
object represents is the distance
between particles and the fact that this
conical object is growing with time
basically means that the distance
between particles is increasing with
time and that's what's called the
expansion of the universe right and so
it just shows that kind of schematically
the universe expanded very quickly at
first that's this inflation shows this
very important a park that we can see
afterglow pattern called the Cosmic
Microwave Background and then you kind
of notice that this is slowing down
because particles exerting gravity are
pulling things together right and
structures form stars form etc etc and
what you see later on is that this again
curves back out so the expansion is
becoming faster this acceleration is
what I just talked about and in fact a
kind of the first major evidence that
people began to take seriously came from
supernova cosmology
for this and this was discovered in the
late 90s and it was a the the three
people who were strongly involved in
this were awarded the nobel prize in
2011 so what's happened now is that we
we understand that there's something
going on but we don't exactly know what
that is and therefore the way to go
forward is to quantify this expansion at
late times very precisely right so
basically we want to come up with new
probes but we also want to take the
probes that we had and do them more
precisely so that we can say that the
universe is not just accelerating at
lake times but exactly how it's
accelerating by the way please feel free
to stop me and ask questions if you want
ok so how does this work how do you know
that the universe is expanding by
looking at objects the general answer is
that you look at Astrophysical systems
or things and you look at things that
you think you know something about you
know certain properties and you can
compute the impact of the expansion of
the universe on those properties as you
would observe them and do the comparison
of those systems for supernovae the way
this works is you try to estimate their
intrinsic brightness how much energy
they were giving out in light and has it
has the light travels to us of course it
it goes in all directions so you get a
much smaller amount of light energy in
any unit area and this is affected by
the expansion because due to the
expansion in takes more time and is even
spread out over larger areas so if you
look if you knew what the intrinsic
brightness of the supernovae work and
it you tried to compare the time at
which they were they were emitting the
light and how much brightness you
measure you should be able to say
something about the expansion history
that's kind of the notion here is is
that a question ok so the next thing I
want to kind of do is talk a little bit
about the kind of data that we have and
it's it's not just the kind of data we
have it's also the kind of data we are
going to be getting from experiments
like the large sky large synoptic Sky
Survey and actually I'm going to use
some of the stuff that has been set up
there because I think that will be an
easy way of explaining how this works ok
so just to give you some feel about this
the large synoptic sky telescope it has
a really large field of view it's 9.6
square degrees and its supposed to scan
2,000 square degrees of the southern sky
with a very high resolution camera which
is 330 200 mega pixels so it's going to
give digital images of the sky each
field of view for every time it points
the telescope at the sky and it's going
to continue doing that in different
colors so I can so this is a youtube
video that LSST has put up which kind of
explains what i am trying to say so you
have the place where all the light is
going to come and you have these optical
objects which are actually called
filters right and when that is in place
in front of the camera the only light
that's going to come in
is of a particular color and actually
color is a kind of a gross way of
putting it it's a sloppy way I'll give
you a slightly better definition
immediately and so these are actually
the filters that you were seeing these
different colored filters have the
effect of stuff stopping light so you
know this one is called you this is G
our eyes ey and when one of these
filters is on let us say the you filter
the only light that's going to come in
is light which has wavelengths in
between this range and even in that case
this is the probability of a photon at
the top of the atmosphere actually
coming into the camera so since we are
going to be taking data with one filter
at a time you are only going to get
light from each of these things and then
the telescope is going to scan the sky
this is also a video that's up on
YouTube actually i will put the link in
later i forgot and what this is showing
is a very very fast you know accelerated
very quickly showing how the telescope
scans the sky and the colors actually
represent the filters that we just saw
so this is why and it will stop scanning
in Y and then it will scan in another
color and now it's doing G and so on
right so this is how it's going to look
at different parts of the sky and I'm
not going to continue with that video
but at the end this is an experiment
there's a survey that's going to
continue for 10 years and at the end you
will be able to add up all those images
that you had of particular areas of the
sky and this is what you get in
different filters so what this shows is
essentially how
dem an object you would be able to see
because of that co edition so Marco
edition obviously means you get higher
signal-to-noise and therefore you can
see dimmer objects and for example here
what's being shown is 26 plus 1.24
that's twenty seven point two three four
that's the red part and something which
has a magnitude of 27 point you for is
going to be detected at something like a
5 Sigma level is what it's saying and so
here higher numbers means it's dimmer
and so that means you visited these
points many many many times more and so
this these you know red points if are
actually selected points where the
survey is supposed to go more times they
are called the deep drilling fields for
various scientific criteria but coming
back to transients are like supernova
that we were talking about what you get
are sort of these individual exposures
in different bands this is actually an
example from a previous Sky Survey Sloan
Digital Sky Survey and you get two pairs
of images one is what's called a
template image maybe Biko edition or
something and one is the search image
which is what you just saw when you scan
that part of the sky and you have to
take a difference of these two and see
if some object is there because that's a
transient so transient is something that
happens at very short time scales like
supernovae they're on for a few weeks
and so per image you see what the
difference the new light there is and
how bright that is that's kind of the
thing that's done and this is a very
complicated process but there are people
who are working on those algorithms but
what all of this is going to give
is something like this which we call
light curve and that is the flux or the
amount of light that you think that
object had how bright that was at the
surface of the earth as a function of
time ok so that's what it is like and so
this is a particular supernovae that the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey had and this
kind of data is called photometric data
so it's really digital images but the
source really is not that right so we've
kind of thrown away degrees of freedom
and just as an example let me show you
this is 2011 Fe which is a really well
observed supernovae it it came on in
2011 that's how the designations work
and it has it so well known it has its
own Wikipedia page but this is kind of
the light curve that it has because it
was very nearby it had it has been
observed really frequently but there
people also have spectra and what you
see is what I'm going to describe as a
time series of spectra right so this
thing that you you're seeing this wiggly
line this is the amount of light light
energy coming in per unit area per unit
time but that in bins of wavelength but
it actually changes with it actually
changes with time and what I'm actually
showing is of course interpolated but
the thing to bear in mind is even though
we have this light curve type of data
the underlying object has more degrees
of freedom and they are described by
spectral time series now I said that the
main thing that you want to do is figure
out how bright those are
jets are because that's instrumental in
finding out how the universe was
evolving and if you look at the data
that I kind of showed this just tells
you how bright it was at the earth not
intrinsically right so going from that
to intrinsic brightness is a sort of a
problem that people have dealt with a
lot and you can sort of understand that
in order to decouple these there have to
be features that are different it's not
just the brightness so think of
something like a night lamp and 100-watt
bulb right if they actually look
different in shape here but if they had
features that were different then you
could actually distinguish between what
is intrinsically 100-watt bulb but looks
dim because it's far away and a night
lamp which looks bright perhaps because
it's nearer to your eyes okay and the
way this has been done is by training on
a very large number of supernova light
curves and spectra so that supernovae at
similar times have similar brightnesses
unless some feature is changing so this
has been done i'm not going to describe
this process today and it has been done
in multiple ways and the one that i am
sort of going to try to use is salt
model and what this does is actually it
trains a spectral x series surface even
though most of the data that it is
training with is photometric so there's
a lot of regularization that's required
to do that and that's that anyway what
I'm trying to the kind of codes that I'm
going to talk about our codes that
actually will work on the test data and
so what you
do is for each supernova that you get in
your sample you're going to try so
actually there's a step that you need to
convince yourself that this is indeed a
supernova 1a and then you are going to
try to fit that to the salt model and
get a few parameters that the salt model
has so you can think of those parameters
as principal components it's it's
slightly more than principal components
because there's a multiplicative factor
that's taken out first but it's
something like principal components plus
a multiplicative factor that has been
modeled so now I'm going to try and talk
about some code so this is SN Cosmo the
main author is Scylla Barbary he's at
Berkeley and it's actually very easy to
install you can install it using tip or
a setup script or Conda it's almost
entirely written Python except parts
that become a little slow and therefore
siphon was used but mostly oh it's a
well-documented I will just show you
soon and large parts have been tested
with unit tests mostly it you tries to
use packages that are already in the
Python ecosystem so numpy syfy a strap I
and even a few others here and there are
often used and this is kind of the read
the docs page you can look at that this
documentation there's a landing page
there's a mailing list if somebody tries
this and has trouble there's even a chat
room and that's the DOI and so this is
meant to be a Python implementation for
supernova cosmology related stuff
mostly from the stage that we get light
curves and onwards so it's not it's not
we haven't I don't think there is a plan
that we will put in stuff that goes from
the images to those light curves that I
said there's a very important step that
will be in a different place but all
other things that we have to do after
that try to put in here so such such
software actually already exists this is
not the first time this is there the the
one that I've used most in that kind is
SN Anna and one major difference is that
those software often are executables and
they're designed for a set of tasks so
there are executables they have
arguments but here there is no major
script it's basically a library of
various functions and these are very
useful primitives it's the kind of
primitives that you would think of if
you were for example thinking okay if I
had that spectrum and it passed through
those filters what is the amount of
light i would get those are the kinds of
primitives that are there very easily so
it's very easy to reuse that api and
perform other tasks tailored to your
needs a bit about the architecture so
this treats the supernova as a source
emitting a time series spectrum at its
location and so that's the astrophysical
source and the most basic one is a time
series source you can take that class
and define how you want the spectrum to
evolve through a series of files where
you define x and the spectrum at this
time then it will interpolate and then
there's the stretch source which is
popular in supernovae which is basically
you have a source and think about the
light curves we saw
and the light curve widths in time can
be changed and salty souls is basically
a source that is respecting the salt
model it uses that and then what's there
is it knows how to evolve the source act
some cosmological distance to us so
there's evolution due to the pack and
that includes the effect of the
cosmological model and there are effects
like dust act so when you get light from
distant objects there's dust in the
Milky Way that extinct sit and it takes
it can take care of that and there's
also potentially dust in the host galaxy
of the supernova and it can also do
things like that so it has ways of
handling that and what it gives you from
when you specify what these effects are
is a model which is the observed
spectrum on the earth so it's going to
be a function of time and wavelength and
the model parameters of the source or
whatever else you had so this is
completely central to the scheme this is
the light curve model that we just
talked about so this is flux theta
represents parameters for example i will
show you an example of the salt model
and theta are parameters that define the
salt model once you have that you can
take photometric data and fit that
giving you those parameters of the salt
model which should tell you how bright
the supernova intrinsically was you can
simulate photometric data you can plot
light curves or data and you can use
this for photometric typing or
photometric redshifts I didn't tell you
what photometric typing was but I kind
of once said supernova one is sort of
important there are other kinds of
supernovae they are called core collapse
soup
no way and they have a different
mechanism of explosion and those
supernova don't work in the same way
that I was trying to describe they won't
follow the salt model and they're easier
to identify if you have spectral data
but as I said we want so you can do for
the metric typing that way so i'll just
show a bit of how things look this is a
this is how photometric data is
represented it's an asteroid table some
columns are essential the time modified
Julian date flux flux error 0 point and
the zero point system is essential you
can have other columns they'll be
ignored if it's not necessary you can
plot that as simply as that ok so SN 0
was this table and if you say plot it
will give you that plot you can find the
model parameters for salt of you can use
a maximum likelihood fit and this uses I
mean we under the hood and the way you
do that is simple you instantiate the
model it's saying what the sources if
you know the red shift in this case I
did because it was independently
determined I said that in and I say fit
LC and it gives me the fit the line is
the model through the points and you can
see that it's reasonably good you might
want to do something like a sampling of
the parameters so you might say that I
don't just want the maximum likelihood
estimate I may want to find the
posterior of the model parameters of
salt so these are the model parameters
of salt d naught is the time at which
you saw the peak X naught is an
amplitude x1 is this stretch kind of
object and
color is essentially the slope of the
spectrum and it knows the model because
you tell it that the model is a salt
model and then you you can say I am
going to do an mcmc and these are the
parameters that I want to fit v / m
names model z is the model that I am
fitting to and it gives you the fitted
model MC MC model z and a result which
has a lot of information on that and
this actually uses MC which is a package
by Daniel Foreman Mackey and then I just
plotted it using another package of that
guy triangle and you can visualize what
these contours look like you can look at
what these things the light curves look
like as you plot it along with the data
they were derived from so I'll come to
another thing which is photometric
redshifts redshifts are easy to
determine from spectra but when you have
photometric data of the kind that we are
talking about they are much harder to
determine and determining photometric
redshifts of galaxies is a big project
by itself but as we described we already
have a model for this supernova so you
might say okay why don't I just fit this
and you can do that and now what you
have to add is you have to add in the
red shift has another parameter that you
are adding and you have to specify
certain bounds and this was Sloan data
so I knew that spectroscopic Sloan
supernovae are all you know less than
redshift of point three they're fairly
nearby and if i do that i get a result i
can plot it you can see that the plots
looks very similar and in fact that's
true i just sure so this array is the
set of numbers for those
parameters when Z was known and when Z
is unknown they're a bit worse but
they're not terribly worse and the
errors are larger and so that makes
sense so I would say that's okay but
this is actually not so easy if I were
to change this bound in this case I was
lucky I knew reasonably well what this
was but if i change this bound and make
this a much larger thing then i'm going
to have trouble with it and that's
actually one of the complicated
situations that we are running into
because and it stems from the fact that
the template that we started with is
finite you can do simulations and i'm
going to just skip over that because i
want to talk a bit about a necessity i
don't have much time left so the lfs t
software framework is a really big
effort the data is going to come in a
few more years but there's been a lot of
effort in developing software that can
deal with that data and not just LSST
data all of this software can be used
for astronomical data in general right
now this is a recent development this is
very easy to install using Conda X about
15-20 minutes once you have anaconda
python or even mini Conda and I'm going
to talk a bit about the LSST simulation
catalog and this is being built in order
to test different analysis methods so if
you have simulations you can try to come
up with the sort of images that we
talked about and see if image
differencing works and you can get light
curves well it's also important to
understand how to optimize the survey
strategy if we have these simulations
and we already have a at logs of
galaxies and stars which are all static
objects so one question that we are
dealing with here is how do we implement
kranz Ian
like super nova because you now need
fluxes and other observations for every
time you observed things right you
require those values and because it's
now going to be and since we don't
actually know when we will be observing
a particular part of sky this means we
need to do this for many observations
and a requirement that we have is that
these catalogs need to be consistent so
if you take a different survey strategy
you should still be able to look at the
same kind of the same set of objects
that are there so the basic method that
we'd like to follow is will generate
supernova observations on the fly
depending on when are the telescope is
pointing according to the simulation and
we'll use the supernova model like soil
to provide sets as a function of model
parameters and these properties are
going to be assigned on the basis of
seeds from the galaxy catalog so that's
what's going to incur things and this
will have this consistency requirement
that if we see a supernova today in the
catalog in a galaxy and then go back
next witness day we will actually see
the same supernova four days later right
so that's what we need to be able to do
and we can use the some of the work done
ness and cosmo so as an object is kind
of a structure that is essentially SN
cosmo but with SN Kozma model that we
talked about but with fixed source less
flexibility but added attributes for
LSST and then we have a catalog which
uses actually the LSST software which is
the instance catalog framework that's
already there and what this does is it
prints out catalogs it prints out
catalogs
in a particular spatial area at a single
in exposure time and the way this is
being done is that it gets the
information from the static galaxy
catalog that's already there so it reads
what galaxy is there that sets the
random seed that tells you the
properties of the supernova and once you
know the properties of the supernova you
know how to get the flux from them in
the ways that we talked about and that's
done by as an object and so this is a
way in which we could address this
problem and i will just put up a summary
where I'll note that supernova cosmology
with this kind of photometric surveys
requires several steps and a lot of
these steps will benefit from good
algorithms and code and we do have ways
of doing these things but they actually
all can be improved and python has a
number of packages now that can be used
for these kinds of steps and of the
things that I described we are currently
working on scaling the results for much
larger number so that we can run those
tests that's all I was going to say but
I'd be happy to take questions
you